you
hi it's Linda and I'm back now I'm going
to show you extra interpretation and
hopefully you will have learned
something from your previous lessons on
the body and we're going to see how much
you remember so the first thing is this
is a view box and these are x-rays so I
need to teach you some basic
interpretations so what I did here is I
put some coins on there and I put a
paperclip and I put a safety pin and
your body has in it an organ that is
filled with air and remember that what
that was that was your long but your
organ has solid things in it that I just
showed you and those are bones so when
you think about a paper clip and you
think about coins and you think about a
safety pin are they made of air are they
made of water which remember you're
mostly made up of water are they made of
something solid they're made of
something solid therefore anything
that's solid comes out white on an x-ray
there's air between those solid things
which means anything that's air-filled
will be black and this is a water
balloon because I needed you to see what
water would look like on x-ray and that
dark circle inside the water balloon
darkness means air so we begin the
lesson by saying anything solid will be
white anything air-filled will be black
and anything that is water is this
grayish color and the black and the
inside is air within that space so if
you have that down will begin so this is
kind of an easy one what do you think
this is so you can see this is your hand
and remember we have about 206 bones in
the body and you have over 25 in your
hand alone so this is the normal hand
and now i'm going to show you this now
besides two hands what do you notice you
notice that metal comes out much whiter
than bone and that's important so if we
left a piece of metal in you after
surgery that would show up as a brighter
white spot than normal bone so we have
two hands here and we have lots of
jewelry ok now we're part of the body is
this so this is the skull and you can
see it looks like teeth look like bone
but they're not really bone so teeth are
made of enamel and it looks like bone
but it's not so this is one skull this
is a different skull so besides it being
a side view of the skull what do you
notice do you notice the teeth look
different you see again normal teeth and
you see the teeth over there why would
the teeth look so white I'll pull back
this x-ray see if you can think about it
you see the metal on the x-ray because
this person had gold teeth so you can
see that the metal is showing up as much
wider you can also make out that she has
earrings on and you can make out that
there is also a necklace on this person
so again a skull view earrings teeth
much wider so we know they're made of
metal and a necklace ok what part of the
body is this
so remember when I showed you the arm
bones and remember when I describe them
as being twisted can you see that so you
can see the twist of the arm bones okay
now what's going on here's another image
of that here's another image of the arm
so here's the hand again and you can see
that this is the radius remember and
this is the ulna and remember I said
they're twisted you see that so that's
the arm what happened to this kid now
you see that we have broken the bone
completely here can you see that a break
here and that break is what they call a
telescoping fracture that bone shoved
into the other bone and again a break
over here so this person would have to
go to surgery to have that fracture fix
so an orthopedic surgeon would come in
and this is what it looks like after
surgery some breaks can't be just casted
you have to align the broken parts so
you can see that there's a bar put in
and they're screws put in and what would
these things be what are those little
squares those are staples so that's the
new form of stitching is a special
surgical stapler that puts the wound
together so again this is how that arm
fracture was repair about this
what bone was that remember that's your
pelvis and remember how I said your hip
bones fit right into there and remember
we called it a ball and socket joint so
this is the largest bone in your body
the femur this is the ball and socket
joint and that's your pelvis okay now
this is really hard I don't know if
you're going to be able to see it so
this is really hard to try to make out
I'll give you a second and then I'll
show you this is the frontal sinus right
here so it's a side view and you can see
the nose can just make out the nose and
there's a tiny bone this is the only
bone that's left your nose this is
cartilage all here but this is bone and
there is a very tiny crack right there
in the bone so that's a nose fracture so
now what part of the body is this went
over it so we have the foot and remember
i said to you that bigger bone comes
down and grabs the ankle on the side and
then the other bone comes down the outer
bone the weaker one if you will the
fibula grabs it on the other side so
this is again what it looks like so
remember the inner ankle is the big bone
comes down and grabs that ankle the
outer ankle comes down and they are what
keep your ankle in place they lock your
ankle so now if that's normal tell me do
you see anything in this x-ray so you
notice how that elephant's nose remember
I described it as an elephant's nose is
supposed to be right up against that
bone and instead there's a space that I
could put my finger in through so this
force pushed the ankle over and then
we have little breaks on the bone on the
outside bone remember the fibula that
was the weaker bones so then this is the
same kid all fixed up so remember now
you can see the bar in there and you can
make out one two three four screws
inside that bone to hold it in place and
then you can make out the metal on the
outside and those are staples and some
fractures some breaks need to have
something extra an extra almost vice
grip to hold it in place it's not left
on there long so this is called external
traction to make sure that everything is
set perfectly okay next what do we have
huh what do we have here so we can see
the spine and remember I said it's not
one bone but a bunch of little bones a
bone a pillow a bone a pillow a bone a
pillow a bone a pillow they call those
pillows disks and see the ribs can you
make out the ribs this is the 11th and
the 12th rib now I want you to try to
follow my finger I'm going to trace
something here is an organ you can see
it's around the eleventh and twelfth
read any idea what organ is in the back
around the eleventh and twelfth rib it's
the kidney this is a plastic model of
the kidney and the kidney is really red
when you see the kidney and the reason
is the kidney is drop cleaning every
drop of blood in your body every drop of
blood is going to your kidney six times
every hour it's constantly being cleaned
so your kidneys are really really
important because they're what's making
sure bad stuff has gotten rid of good
stuff is reabsorbed that we need so the
kidneys are really important they sit
way way in the back around the eleventh
and twelfth rib
this is a real kidney and we took all
the blood out of it and removed all the
fat but that you could see what the size
of the real kidney looks like once we
remove the fat protection that's around
the kidney so this is your spine this is
your pelvis this is your eleventh and
twelfth rib and here is the shadow of
your kidney now if I really wanted to
see your kidney well I could do
something we could bring you in for a
procedure and I could put a special dye
in your bloodstream because didn't I say
every drop of blood goes to your kidney
six times every hour and I could wait
one hour now in one hour that died that
I put in your bloodstream would have
gone to your kidneys to be cleaned your
kidneys don't need the dye so they get
rid of the die and now you can see the
kidneys actually light up see the
kidneys now much better picture of the
kidneys and you can see that there's
some weight coming down and then it goes
away and then it opens back up again so
this way down here is your bladder most
people think your bladder is up here
near your belly button it's not look how
low down it is so you can see it
completely lit up and how come it's not
white all the way down because this is a
muscle that's squeezing to push the died
down now look on this side you can see
the kidney but now we can't see any
connection over to the other side
there's absolutely no connection so this
was a person that had a kidney stone so
we couldn't get any of the dye out
through that side so also do you notice
over here what are those things isn't
that the same kind of color that the
jewelry was so these were meant little
metal clips that were left in place when
the person had surgery previously okay
now I didn't talk about this at all this
if these are your intestines you have 21
feet of bowel 21 feet of bowel at a
minimum below your diaphragm which
remember was that muscle that was
important to breathe and above the
symphysis pubis that bone right in the
middle 21 feet of bowel in here and it
looks like snakes you see so this is
your intestine now what are these any
idea what that is ribs but that's not a
real x-ray can't be a real x-ray what
did I tell you the ribs protect didn't I
tell you they protect the heart the
lungs deliver the stomach where are they
so this is a fake x-ray this is a real
x-ray so when you look at a real x-ray
you can see couple things this was the
most frequently broken bone what did I
say it was the clavicle or the
collarbone remember it's white it's
solid remember black means air-filled
look how you see air one inch above the
inner one third of the clavicle because
this is where a lung is so your lungs
rise one inch above the inner one third
and they come on down and I always look
in the corner to make sure I see the
blackness in the corner come on in to
see the blackness in the corner so these
are this is your right lung this is your
left lung and this is your heart so this
is your aorta the arch of your aorta
coming down and this is your heart
sitting right here see the black coming
down here why is there black coming down
there because when we ask you to take an
x-ray we say take a deep breath and you
can see the black air going down and
being captured by this x-ray in the
person's trachea so persons inhaling the
lungs are completely expanded and
there's the heart that sits right there
on
left side so that's one heart now what
do we have here so now we have a person
again we look different x-rays different
size lungs again the lungs rise one inch
above the inner one third of the
clavicle we look in the corner we see it
coming down we look in the corner we see
it coming down do you see that black
spot right there black means air what
organ is right there that's your stomach
so that friends is a burp so you can see
what a burp looks like on x-ray this is
your liver largest organ inside the body
so there's the liver here's the stomach
darkness inside means air so air inside
the stomach is a burglar then we have
another x-ray with now what do you see
right away so can you see how this
person is breathing with far less long
than the other side look how we're
pinched down over here to this corner
nothing here so this person's long was
filled with fluid so you can see that
the fluid look like the water balloon
doesn't it so the marking goes away the
blackness goes away can you also make
out wires here you make out that wires
so this is a person that had open-heart
surgery so you can see that the wires
were done so the person's taking a
breath in you can see the blackness
coming down but it's curved over a
little bit we don't like to see that we
like to see that coming straight down
okay so that's along this one now is a
little bit different again this is a
younger person a thinner person we see
the ribs we see the lungs rise one inch
above the blackness above we go down to
the corner this is the liver here's the
stomach and we see air inside the
stomach the little black burps but now I
want you to notice how
if I cover my hand doesn't that look
just like the fake x-ray over here does
because there's no lung tissue there
that lung collapse can you make out now
the shadow of the loan so that was a
collapsed lung and that's easily treated
when you come into the hospital and then
this is another picture of the person
that had fluid on the lung looking like
the water balloon and again you can see
all the wires that were used to then
rewire the lungs back together again the
lungs the sternum back together again
and then this is what an MRI looks like
just to show you how pretty early so you
can see we'll pick this one first what
part of the body is that the skull and
you can see what the eyeballs look like
this is your brain and remember I said
only one inch protects your brain from
hair to brain and this shows how thin
the skull really is so again really
important that you wear a helmet this is
your spinal cord and you can see this is
the exact same image but they're able to
change it so that in this picture i can
pay attention to the spinal cord and in
this picture i can pay attention to the
bones itself so again look here bone
pillow bone pillow these your disks and
this is the biggest nerve coming out
going down through the spinal cord these
are your hip bones on either side a bone
on top a bone on the bottom and a bone
on front it's only one bone that would
do that a bone on top a bone on the
bottom and a bone in front so this is a
picture of your knee joint this is your
heel and then this is the most
frequently dislocated bone in the
do you remember from the skeletal what
that would be and that's your shoulder
joint so that are that is your your
little quiz on if you learn something
today you'd be able to interpret the
x-rays okay alright so I hope you
learned something today and mostly I
guess I'd like you to come away that the
human body is incredibly complex and
sophisticated but also simplistic in its
design